congratulations on the movie
saw it yesterday uh thoroughly enjoyed
it
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes
of the making of uh film you know stuff
that i might not know
um what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of
stillwater
um i think just that we got to um
you know i got to at least for me spend
a lot of time talking with people
um at label met the prison a lot of the
guards um all the guards that you see in
the movie are real
guards that actually work there so um
i kind of got to walk through and see
what my
day-to-day life would be like in there
and um
you know it just felt very uh we tried
to do everything really authentically
and
um i hope that that comes across um when
people see it
a hundred percent i think one of the
reasons it does is because
uh tom has this knack with dialogue
about making it like
very authentic and it doesn't feel like
a hollywood script it feels like you're
watching real life people you know real
people just on a movie screen
can you sort of talk about the i guess
the script and tom's dialogue
yeah i think that um i was really lucky
uh
that when you have such a great script
to work with it kind of
makes your job a lot easier um because
the emotions just kind of come out
because the writing is so
um real and genuine so um i think that's
just a real testament to
um tom and noah and tomah who are the
other writers on it
um just how they really
um found a way to tell uh this story
which is
really complicated in such a truthful
way matt damon
is uh absolutely one of my favorite
actors he just adds this
believability to his performances what
did you take away from working with him
maybe what surprised you about working
with him
um you know he's such a um a really
patient actor and
so generous and and really
collaborative and um
just down to do as many takes as need be
to get it right and um
yeah he's he's super not like full of
himself he
he could be if he wanted to i'm sure but
he's just a super dumb
or earth like normal dad sure
i the thing that i found uh i've gotten
to interview him a number of times
and he's always game to talk about
anything could be scorsese
could be the red sox it could be
anything yeah
did you ever you know geek out with him
over just stupid stuff or you like
remember when you did that movie that
departed that was kind of good
um uh no
i i think mostly
we were just the funniest thing that
happened i think was that
we had to do a scene where i'm driving
the car and he's in it and
uh i believe he was tipped off that i
had gotten my license for the movie
and um there's just one picture of us
sitting in the car and tom's like giving
us some direction and it was right
before i started driving and i'm like
like am i gonna accidentally kill matt
damon and he's just like clenching onto
the side of the door like
terrified probably for his life but he
taught me how to do a u-turn so that was
nice uh my last thing for you is uh you
got to film on location and i think that
added so much to this film
none of it was in a sound stage can you
sort of talk about that experience of
being there really being on location
yeah i think um you know marseille is
such a kind of character in the film and
it's
it's a completely um
different place than anywhere else in
the world in my opinion and so
i think um just getting to be there and
really get a feel for the city and the
energy there
was um was really important to the film
100 on that note i gotta go thank you so
much for your time and congrats on the
movie